[Musique]
je sais le ridicule ne tue pas mais là
en fait l'air de rien on nous sommes en
train de travailler avec ces petites
voix qui normalement répondre à ce bruit
alors ce costume que j'ai là c'est un
costume de travail en fait c'est pour
que ces petits animaux ne s'habitue pas
non pas à l'humain mais aux costumes qui
qui qui en fait et leurs repères donc
l'avantagé ici nous sommes à animal
contacte donc on apprend plein de choses
on a l'air parfois un petit peu ridicule
mais c'est pour le bien de tout le monde
ce que je vous propose c'est découvrir
un petit peu ce qui se passe derrière en
fait le public est amené parfois à
découvrir le métier de soigneur ici je
vous propose tout de suite de regarder
ce reportage que nous avons tourné avec
xavier naizet et jonathan bru elle
visite chez les perroquets il est
l'heure de manger
si caroline est une habituée des lieux
c'est une première pour camille et
marc-antoine soigneur d'un jour
cette visite à animal contact c'est un
cadeau d'anniversaire que monsieur a
fait à madame elle est amoureuse des
bêtes et on avait vu déjà donc un
précédent reportage donc sur le sur les
lieux et puis donc bon voyant ce
reportage j'avais vu le savez ça lui
avait donné envie et donc on est pris la
décision de l'emmener ici en vacances à
l'île de ré ses habitants du pas de
calais au fait un crochet par la région
pour participer à l'activité
c'est fantastique c'est c'est génial
j'adore
alors en plus on est très bien
accompagné c'est vraiment génial de
pouvoir les approcher
c'est des animaux que je n'avais jamais
vu en vrai sonnés les animaux c'est
nettoyer nourrir cajoler parfois en
tenant compte des petites manies de
chacun l'eau la charmante coati est ravi
d'accueillir ses visiteurs l'héroïne des
marchés fille d'amis n'a pas la grosse
tête après le cas là on se retrousse les
manches pour s'occuper des animaux de
nos forêts aller chercher du foie et
prendre les outils nécessaires pour
faire du bon travail
caroline distribuer les rôles elle fait
découvrir son métier et on dit plus sur
les animaux c'est un bonheur de partager
ce qu'on sait sur les animaux ce qu'on
connaît qu'on voudrait transmettre par
foyer des animaux qui ont des mauvaises
réputations parce que l'histoire a voulu
que comme le loup par exemple après
l'effort la découverte un aperçu du
métier de dresseurs camille et
marc-antoine vont d'abord travaillé avec
tito le grand duc
une façon de permet
trop animaux de s'imprégner les humains
le fait que vous veniez faire le travail
des comédiens ça va nous aider beaucoup
regardé l'oiseau entraînés et équipés
pour pour son travail d'acteur autre
approche ce cinéma avec ses petites
grues qui se prépare pour un film nos
soigneurs d'un jour pourront peut-être
dire qu'ils ont contribué à la naissance
d'une grande star du grand écran
heureusement pour notre honneur d'un
jour ils n'ont pas eu à se revêtir de
cet accoutrement
mais plus sérieusement c'est vraiment un
costume de travail 1 c'est vraiment pour
que ces petits toits qui sont derrière
nous puissent apprendre leur travail
nous allons en discuter tout de suite
avec jean-edouard qui est à côté de moi
qui connaissait sur le bout des doigts
en fête se prépare pour la suite c'est
un petit peu salace et pour qu'elle
s'habitue à ce costume à l'allumage et
dans un costume tel que celui ci c'est
ça l'idée exactement en fait on est en
train de jouer le papa et la maman
déguisés pour qu'ils puissent assimiler
en fait
les parents sedan ce déguisement est pas
un être humain en particulier un
soigneur en particulier alors le
soigneur on en parle et là on a
découvert des gens qui qui qui était
avec des professionnels et qui
découvraient ce métier c'est une des
animations que vous mettez en place je
crois que vous avez envie d'ouvrir un
maximum de monde un petit peu votre
univers c'est un petit peu l'impression
qu'on a un souvenir d'un jour les
immersions il ya pas mal de choses qui
sont proposés voilà on a plein de
propositions de notre principale
activité c'est quand même le cinéma mais
effectivement on a envie de partager
avec le public
le notre métier est aussi la passion des
animaux donc montrer les différentes
facettes
le dressage les soins pour les animaux
alors laissons on vient de le voir mais
l'immersion ça se passe comment je crois
qu'il ya deux catégories on y aller il
ya les grands animaux des forêts et les
loups c'est ccxr vous de vos deux points
d'intérêt c'est ça je crois on a 2 2
immersion effectivement avec les grands
animaux le cerf et les
les daims chez les daims les sangliers
et on a les immersions avec les loups
les adultes qui ont déjà cinq ans donc
on en a déjà fait un petit peu et on a
dernièrement les sept louveteaux donc
qu'on pourra pas voir puisque bamyan
delbecque non plus n'est pas là les
partis en tournage dans le cantal faire
un film avec tous les loups donc non il
ya le bec c'est la personne qui est là
c'est la grande chef on va dire ça comme
ça ça ne touche personne c'est la grande
chef d'animal contacte donc l amiable
énormément de films qui ont été tournés
avec tous ces animaux qui sont ici là
tout à l'heure on a vu des grues qui
s'entraînait en fait là on a des petites
voix mais il ya des grandes lois qui ont
joué dans un film qui va bientôt sortir
voilà là c'est notre relève c'est pour
la sortie du film donne moi des ailes de
nicolas vanier qui va sortir le 9
octobre
donc là c'est la nouvelle génération on
va pouvoir les faire voler en ulm
comme dans le film en fait et alors le
but du jeu c'est de vraiment de ceux de
s'ouvrir un maximum je crois qui est
encore plein d'idées qui tourne dans la
tête autour de autour du cinéma autour
des animaux il ya une passion à partager
c'est clair c'est un truc comme ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on veut partager un
maximum parce qu'on aime ça et c'est
vrai qu'on va jusqu'à proposer bientôt
en septembre des tentes dans les bois
pour pouvoir entendre hurler les loups
dans la nuit alors en attendant on va
rouler des loups on va rappeler les
petites voix mais bon ça marche pas bien
avec moi en fait elle ne m'aime pas du
tout je ne suis pas fait pour que chez
les animaux
on se retrouve demain peut-être j'espère
on aura un autre costume fin jouera
notre costume merci beaucoup et ça
marche toujours pas à bientôt